if you saw the human being as a computer
you could program the human being just
like just lift it up a little more so
people can see the whole title oh the
book I thought you're the same lift up
my spirit
yeah well the way that they came over
the way that they Influence People now
is subconscious but but they're moving
into a new kind of way where we are
going to have some kind of implantable
chip inside of us today at the world
economic Forum a Duke Professor Anita
farhani actually talked about how in the
very near future we're going to have
sensors in each ear in order to monitor
your brain waves all day every day so uh
we already have wearable technology now
we're going to have implantable
technology and if you thought the
subconscious psyop propaganda in the in
the Hollywood movies by the CAA it was
bad imagine what happens when they get
access to your brain waves and are able
to manipulate that and stimulate that
for what they want to encourage and what
they want to do discourage this is next
on the singularity has a whole chapter
on that very thing where he says that
they'll they'll step in between the data
that comes in from the exterior to your
mind and they'll have a layer in there
to tell you what's coming in and it
won't be the actual exterior data that's
coming in from the external world it's
what they want to hear he says it'll be
done eventually by not by nanotech when
he was doing this back in the 60s he was
doing the actual like RFID chip right
putting it in the monkey or whatever but
in this book it actually talks about
experimenting on humans and these are
the same I just want to make one more
Point here these are the same
intelligence agencies that are already
saying you can't listen to this you
can't hear this they are denying you
access to information on social media
curating the algorithms denying people
spanning people imagine what they're
going to do when they're inside of your
head but why was that guy
cranking off a dolphins
a hard question because mad scientists
are freaks yeah yeah because I remember
reading about something like that and
then but is is he an evil guy like is
this book he's writing talking about his
intentions that are bad or is he writing
a warning about what they're going to do
and he just so happened to be a creeper
who cranked a dolphins no he's the 100
part of it like he he's a believer in it
so I mean I think all the M kiltered
doctors were were Believers well how
come how come all these people these
Global Elites do weird weird stuff you
know what I mean because when you get so
much I mean one Theory I mean we don't
know exactly some people believe there's
a spiritual a component to this some
people believe that they're taken over
by demons another aspect is
psychologically speaking when you have
so much power when you have so much
money there's things that just don't
affect you at all so they keep looking
for new bizarre crazy things that
actually give them some kind of feeling
in this life since they're so numb by
how much they have already accomplished
in this world that's that's another
theory there's other theories
one of the theories is that people who
want to do really messed up things seek
power in order to immunize themselves
from the law and society as they seek to
do it so like I don't know what level of
power this guy had but certainly someone
who wants control who's got messed up
predictions about dolphins is going to
need to insulate themselves from the law
if they're gonna do weird crap like that
and then you got the o Epstein stuff
clearly these people want to get
positions of power so that it's very
difficult to go after I mean look Andrew
prince Andrew why isn't that guy getting
charged
I mean what's up with that you know
Maxwell Goes to Jail what about The
Client List these people seek power
because then they can get they can then
get away with it because you look at you
look at what happens to people who
aren't in the club like those two guys I
think where was it those two guys with
Atlanta or something where they were
trapped they adopt two gay guys adopted
kids and then started raping and
trafficking them for money those guys
got arrested and people are calling for
the death penalty for what they did but
then take a look at the Epstein stuff
and it's like where is The Client List
people who wanted who want to do messed
up crap like that seek power so they can
become you know if they were politicians
those two two guys they probably would
have gotten away with it
um that's another aspect that people
understand here and a lot of these
people are just sociopaths so that's a
third explanation so I have I have these
kind of two explanations one they're
just kind of sociopaths uh two they're
just kind of numb for having too much
power and then you know one is that
they're they're hijacked by demons
that explains it or all of all three
above right but there's also an element
like in Dr Quigley's traging hope where
he's chronicling the history of the
elite in the 20th century he's one of
them by the way he's writing an
apologetic interesting hope there's a
chapter where he talks about
how the elite raised their children and
there's a at least in the British
tradition he's talking about the Royal
Society that they have the tradition to
intentionally inculcate psychopathy and
so one of the reasons that they would
send them to Elite boarding schools was
to separate them from the matronly you
know raising this kind of has a natural
production of psychopathy there's also
inbreeding as well and some of the Royal
Society groups which also can produce
that and by the way the reason to answer
that previous question about the tip of
the spear that's because
um that's a reference to the ongoing
Revolution that Huxley wrote about so if
you read Huxley not just Brady new world
but his other text he has an essay at
the beginning of brand new world where
he says that this is the culmination of
all the Revolutions of the last several
centuries and that culmination is in a
strictly tiered technocratic Society
where everybody's controlled and babies
are born in in test tubes so it's it's a
it's an actual plan of Revolution that
continues up into transhumanism I I
think about like uh people that have so
much money and power starting to take
the NPC metaphor literally and then they
look at people and they start to look at
them as biomechanical machines and how
do you manipulate and control the
machine right as a and then so you lose
it that's I I do like saying like hey
people are NPCs hahaha but the reality
is no we're all humans and uh we all
have human rights in my opinion and we
should support those but I see that
happening well it's treated like a
machine so how do we tweak the machine
yeah what do you think is the the
biggest biggest fight that's happening
right now because we are going through
as Klaus Schwab says a fourth Industrial
Revolution but where do you think the
front line of the fight is is it is it
AI is it social media is it
um you know the subconscious propaganda
how do you see this fight unfolding and
where's the number one fight happening
now well I have religious views so I
think that ultimately there's a
spiritual component that you were
talking about I do think at least
certain sections of the elite there is a
demonic possession that occurs so I
would agree with that
um so that's kind of the big picture in
my view but then
um yeah I think that if we don't stop
the implementation of a complete Tech
control grid it's over yeah like I was
watching this video of uh journalists
trying to interview class Schwab at
Davos a few days ago did you guys see
that and this girl and he's like
ignoring her ignoring her like he
doesn't have time he doesn't have time
and so I I want a light class I want to
be like maybe he's got his own path to
World unification I don't necessarily
agree with but I still I don't think
he's I think he thinks he's doing good
so in this interview she's trying to
interview me walks away he comes back
and he's like who are you this who are
you this what company and she's like I'm
independent and he's like oh yeah Okay
and like why are you a dick Klaus like
don't be a dick dude we need
that that's what you can say yeah maybe
he is maybe he's actually like a nasty
guy I want to like him you thought these
people were nice well he's got Chris why
do you want to like these crazy
Charisma they just use it for evil like
okay that's the problem with Charisma is
it can be used very nefariously well I
brought this classic about technocratic
age and I think you know him
he talked about a lot of this stuff too
way before it was even as as relevant as
it is today he really uh being your
Brzezinski uh was one of one of the
biggest uh you know representatives of
the Rockefeller family he was a part of
the counts on Foreign Relations the
Bilderberg Group their trilateral
commission uh he was the presidential uh
uh advisor and truly was also The
Mastermind behind the Mula hajin and the
Taliban uh in Afghanistan as well it was
uh he was the first person that I
confronted and had to run away from uh
security
after doing so on YouTube right yeah and
fear for my life
yeah between two ages yeah and then the
book The subtitle is the best part
because it's America's role in
technocratic Era he's not around anymore
but his daughter is of course Mika
versus evil on MSNBC oh wow um and uh I
confronted him specifically about him
talking about the great neural order and
him starting essentially Al Qaeda and
him being responsible for doing so in
American tax dollars with a foreign
policy move that bid us uh in the back
and also having culpability in the
events that happened in New York City on
9 11. so it was a very interesting
conversation uh watch it's the first
video I think if you go to my YouTube
channel we are change you go to the
oldest video you'll see that right there
but he talked about a lot of this
technocratic stuff what was your biggest
takeaway from between two ages
between two ages has essentially all of
the plan laid out in the 19 uh early 70s
and it caught the eye of David
Rockefeller so he talked to Kissinger
about this book and he's like I like
that guy get him in some kind of
steering committee yes yes we will do
that we'll create a steering committee
right away that's literally what they
did they had a conversation
they created trilateral commission and
then boom uh there's a big news there
zbix they're running it and he's
basically from the behind the scenes
like you said doing a lot of the uh the
Black Ops and all this kind of stuff but
the book is really just saying that all
of reality will have to change and we're
right now and he's saying the 70s in
this position between
the great reset right I mean he doesn't
use that terminology but it's the exact
same plan that's the point is like you
go all the way back to H.D Wells you
know 100 years ago and he was laying out
with Bertrand Russell in the Royal
Society in the fabians the socialist
society the exact same plan that
brzezinski's talking about it's it's to
the to a t yeah you know the funny thing
about it is like the the progenitors of
the New World Order and the great reset
and all this stuff are all very very old
or dead and the people they're giving it
to who are inhering it inheriting it are
incompetent and performance but they're
failing yeah they're fumbling and the
the plebs they were supposed to control
are are privy to what they're doing and
we're complaining about it and it's just
it's funny because I like I just want to
imagine you go back to like Jekyll
Island and all the weird plans and the
Federal Reserve and they're like well I
have absolute control and then 100 years
later they're grandchildren are
like I have no idea what I'm doing and
it's just all falling apart we're gonna
tell you what the metaverse
for the rest of your life your vitamins
will be souped into your body
I've explained this to people
you're going it's going to start like
this okay we're doing remote work we're
in lockdown number two just put on your
your metaverse headset sit in your chair
and then you're using the joysticks to
move around
a few years go by a few generations of
Virtual Technology no one will leave
their houses you'll wake up you won't
shower or brush your teeth because you
will already be in your pod when you
wake up you'll just click the button on
your visor and then you will be in the
front of your Virtual Office Building
and you a dragon will walk in where
hockey players are walking around
talking about sales pitch numbers and a
giant carrot walks up to you and says
look you didn't get the report done last
night I need the report when all sudden
his boss a rabbit walks over and says I
don't want to get any negativity today
we got a big important meeting cover
those reports then you walk into an
office where Super Mario is is doing
sales report meetings because
everybody's gonna identify in weird
weird-ass ways and that's the weird
world you're gonna live in and get this
I shouldn't even say office building
you're going to literally walk into
Bowser's Castle and they're going to be
like we here at Funko sales we like
having a good time so our office
building is is Bowser's Castle and
there's you know princess and Mario were
talking in the corner or whatever it's
just weird and you're going to be
talking business in this crazy broken
world where carrots complaining about
stuff I was picturing people being fed
by tubes of like liquid fluid and uh
then their teeth falling out because
they don't brush them like you were
saying they're in the thing all day they
don't need to wash and clean the teeth
will fall out all of them will fall out
and then they'll start having kids with
no teeth no no no no
noons with no teeth I gotta stop you
people's teeth will actually get way
better because they won't be eating
breads and sugars first
or whatever it may be but we also have
to understand the internet is dominated
by a lot of adult content now imagine
having a VR and being in a place where
you're inundated with the internet and
you're going to be seeing a lot of weird
crazy stuff especially because people
can't kind of unhook and and get away
from it but Jay from your experiences
from what Tim just said how accurate is
that and how do you see the future kind
of shaping uh not by but what you want
but what you've read and what they're
calling for
yeah well that's the world I want right
that's I wanna I wanna right you want to
go to work at Bowser yeah right um your
boss is a dude but he Avatar says
Princess Peach and it's like just
Princess Peach is like look I told you
you couldn't be selling these things in
the office these digital widgets I'm
sorry Peach I mean Jim back to the
Brickyard with you smash him with your
head get it no I mean so the well in uh
Jacques de Lee's book brief history of
the future he has a section where he
talks about that when you're basically
in the pod phase you're gonna be
you're going to be bitched around
by a robot that will be your monitor so
I mean he actually it's all planned out
to where it's like you won't get access
to the outside world except through this
like bot monitor that that tells
you anything that you need to know so
that's kind of what the chat gbt that's
rolling out is this early phase of what
you see in movies like Spike Jones is
her
um there's also a really good movie that
makes Tim's point which is called the
Congress I don't know if you've ever
seen that but it's it's a classic with
uh in the Indie sci-fi movie from like
2010. it's got Robin Wright in it and um
they scan her in as an actress and the
company owns the scan she dies but then
like a thousand years into the future
everybody's interacting in the metaverse
as dragons and Mario and whoa It's
called the con it's called the Congress
yeah it's great I want to check that out
that's so funny part of why I'm obsessed
with these contracts what perpetuity is
everybody's in the metaverse like
wearing they're wearing the headset or
whatever it's in their head but
everybody's walking around in tattered
Rags like they're fentanyl zombies but
they're living in the metaverse so have
you seen the video on Philly of the that
drug epidemic or whatever where
everyone's taken some I wrote it's
called but they're all like shaking and
shambling back and forth It's called uh
Flocka no it's not flakka it's not
flocking now the Flocka one makes people
go like and go crazy the Philly one is
like trace or something like that and it
makes people like look like zombies
shaking back and forth I've seen this
too yeah you know in that book we were
just talking about uh zvigny
brzezinski's Between Two Worlds between
two ages I'm two ages I imagine the ages
are the age of the liberal economic
order and the age of the New World Order
and that we are in the middle of a
transition but you said mention the
Fabian Society has also been talking
about this stuff that's 1884 way before
the liberal economic order was formed I
mean technically I guess the British
Empire so is it what the British Empire
is now evolving into a world Empire
correct shrank it's called trank thank
you so so if I could ask you uh sorry I
I didn't mean just grab the book on the
Fabian but I just wanted to ask you Jay
because a lot of people have different
kind of understanding and perspectives
who do you see at the top of the pyramid
here
I know that's a very kind of open-ended
generalized question and kind of hard to
answer but I don't know if the Amish
I'm talking about here the AQ not jokes
um no I think that so at the tip top is
a spiritual Dimension with the devil I
would think there's a real devil I think
that's the best explanation for why this
same sort of model like continues in
history to repeat
um but anyway beyond that I think that
when you look at these you know big
steering committees CFR Council
formulations if you look at
um Davos these are basically frontus
pieces for this inner core which is the
same structure that's been there it's
that secret security apparatus that set
up uh you know no SS the CIA in 1942
1947 it's the British structure The
Milner Roundtable groups that's who's
running this whole thing thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time